In this problem, a 5 MGD water supply is
treated with chlorine. The chlorine
demand is 40% of the chlorine dose. If
the free available chlorine
concentration is measured to be 1.38 mg
per liter, what was the chlorine dose
supplied to the water in millig per
liter?
So, this is a super quick problem, but
it's critical to understand exactly what
chlorine demand is. And unfortunately, I
don't see anything in either the civil
or environmental reference manual to
help with this. Let me know in the
comments if you see something that could
help a person with no background on this
subject to get started. Thankfully, it's
not hard.
Chlorine demand is the amount of
chlorine needed to react with substances
in the water.
The chlorine dose is simply the amount
of chlorine supplied to the water.
Therefore, the free available chlorine
is the amount left over after
subtracting the demand from the dose.
So, the volume of the water supply is
not going to be needed for this problem.
So, let's just get rid of that. Now, we
can see here that the chlorine demand is
given as 40% of the dose.
So we can say that we have the dose
minus
40% of the dose.
[Music]
And the free available chlorine is
measured to be 1.38 mg per liter.
So simplifying this down, the free
available chlorine
of 1.38 mg per liter is going to be
equal to 100% of the dose minus 40% of
the dose
or 60%
of the dose.
If we divide both sides by 60
or rather 60%.
Then we can see that the total dose is
going to be
3 mg per liter
which is our third option over here.
So again, this problem is super easy.
Just make sure to keep this concept in
your head about the free available
chlorine equaling the dose minus the
demand. Or otherwise, find something in
the reference manual that you can use to
help jog your memory. And that's it.